hello hello hello hello everybody how
are you how are you doing dude happy
mother's that Monday yeah do good
Mother's Day yes they were just watching
Tiger my mother was oh I didn't even
watch I mean it was such a blowout by
Webb Simpson and then I had other stuff
to do I mean it was kind of weird my mom
cooked on Mother's Day right and then
allowed it shouldn't be I mean I went I
had my grandma my Tracy my mom we were
eating bagels right then speech about
how much he'd love the family and like
my dad interrupts the dirt I was like
she's like I don't know if this is the
right time for the toast and I was like
I wanted to bake no it's the exact
[ __ ] right time especially she's
given a great BIOS right getting big
filled us what time Berlin toast and we
were like we were already like halfway
through it we all looked at him like
shut up this is Mother's Day not pure
he's got to be the quarterback he's
gotta be exactly that's amazing I'll
tell you what though you're welcome to
Sims and left go it's a very familiar
place oh hello but things are changing
just a little bit are they oh yeah baby
gambling is legal welcome to Sims and
left coops that's right we got plus 220
that this show goes under an hour and 20
we got gambling segments we got all the
things you need the world is our oyster
hear that are you freaking idiots out
there just drain your life savings away
betting on crap you don't know anything
about oh yes they know everything
because they watch left goes LOX
guaranteed winners call now
we can make it happen how about this two
Oakland Raiders moving to Las Vegas that
stadium is still getting built I'm
throwing sports books in there I'm
having betting stations at every seat
you know what I mean right the thing the
thing I'm interested in is I saw a quote
like I don't know all the details of
everything that's still getting fleshed
okay but the one quote I saw Mark Cuban
basically I think made it quote bait
saying that all franchises are gonna
double and worth because of this yes why
I don't get it so the amount of
advertising dollars that can come in now
from like more yeah that's great
right - there's more interest the games
mean more I'm really curious to watch
broadcast and pregame shows like yeah
you can listen to Terry Jimmy and the
boys joke it up and yuk it up but what
if one of these networks comes out with
a gambling preview show because now it's
legal you know that whole cloud has
taken away so what if Fox comes and
they're 30-minute pregame is here's what
we're seeing on the injury reports the
line has moved this much because a big
app [ __ ] big action with some of our
sharks I would put $200 like what if all
these pregame shows just become betting
shows okay yeah I mean all right so wait
does that gonna allow draft kings and
those kind of things to get involved
here again how does that [ __ ] it's
all part of it Lotus I I don't want to
speak for bleacher report yes but we
have an app you're telling me that when
you watch when you watch left ko locks
and underneath it goes you want to bet
with left ko and it does I don't know
but I would offer a bet against left go
you know I mean like bet against land
against left go look man like be are
live just came out with a thing that's
like hey you want to see the last five
minutes of Rockets warriors and then
underneath a like and you could throw
play-by-play money yeah you should you
should set up you should actually that
would be a cool thing that you do on a
weekly basis left ko locks and you go
head-to-head with real money with some
person you guys can like venmo it to
each other like you whatever $10 $20 to
spicing it up a little this is another
example though I've I think how our
content you and me Simpson love Co is
gonna be so different than everybody
else there's gonna be some other shows
out there that kind of embrace gambling
I think it's all a part of
and I think so we're gonna cover the
athletes still we're still gonna cover
the games but we got to do more gambling
we have an entire gambling Joe show
during the season it's called don't
listen to Chris gamble on this game left
Coe has beaten Simms for the last four
years so we're already ready to do Gama
already so we're ready it's super
exciting it's gonna be a lot more money
and you're probably gonna be hearing a
lot of ads on a lot of TV shows and
podcasts about gambling from now on I
think the other big winners are two
people Eli Manning and Matt Patricia Eli
Manning's memorabilia fraud case started
today I haven't heard a single peep
about it yeah haven't heard a peep yeah
you're the other thing was the Matt
Patricia story that came out late last
week a 1996 sexual assault charge that
apparently got dropped because the the
the woman in question didn't want to
testify it's a lot of cloudy stuff I'm
gonna say right now that I'm gonna
reserve all judgment until it flushes
out I will say that for the Detroit
Lions not to have any idea that this
even happened and then as soon as the
accusations come out saying they stand
by their coach you either didn't know
about it and need to read up on it or
you knew about it and felt comfortable
with it but until then I got to see more
information there's just a lot of stuff
would you have hired him if I knew it
would be one of those things where if I
knew what I had all the questions and I
could do the research and talk to the
police and talked and find the witness
like you it's we do this with draft guys
I know I'm shocked this is where I
always think the the outreach of the NFL
power is not as strong as they try to
make it to be I mean you know even going
back to the Ray Rice situation what to
took so long to get that video evidence
don't you have people in the FBI that
the TMZ get it before exactly right that
is weird to me other thing I'll say too
is do you think I'm just conversation
I'm asking you just in talk do you think
Matt Patricia is supposed to come forth
with that information when he's on his
interview to go you know I had this
little incident all right so this kind
of reminds me of billions again I'm
finally up to season three catching up
good thing but there is in season two
the guy I forget the guys name you're a
big fan of this you know Paul Giamatti
whatever his character's name is going
run for governor yes and he sits down
with this woman and she goes this is
your opportunity anything you've ever
done in your life that you think could
come up and bless you the face you tell
me now and I'm gonna try and take care
of it right and like he doesn't tell her
everything in the beginning and then one
thing happens later she goes what that I
think in that moment you you have to
kind of Detroit should have found this
out yeah Detroit should have seen it
right if they never bring it up in a job
interview I don't know if it's up to you
because it sounds like he was already
found innocent in his mind it was
dropped in his mind yeah someone has to
bring it up I think to him but this is
gonna continue to evolve and grow you
know the Patriots come out and Bill
Belichick says I support his character
right I do too I mean I do
if listen if he did we find that he did
something really egregiously wrong here
and everything that it was accused of is
true though you said the same thing with
Ray Rice exactly you said I know Ray
Rice and but the true thing is is the
Ray Rice that you know yes right I'm at
Patricia that you know you didn't know
map attrition 1990s I did not know I
know I don't I don't like though just
from a human perspective I don't like
saying oh it was spring break and I also
don't like saying he's a good guy
because it makes it seem like the victim
possible victim here like had an mo yeah
no no I usually stand for the I always
stand for the victim yeah I do I do too
yeah I mean there's there's too much
gray area to even really talk about this
hardcore but yeah I will say that I do
vouch for the guy that I've been around
right I understand that your right is a
long time ago he was 21 years old -
there is something to that but yes I do
feel for the girl I mean of course I do
I mean I got a mom I got daughter but
worse but at the same time you know I've
talked about this before I've seen
situations that are shady about this too
and I'm not gonna try to get my net to
ever say because look there's a lot of
gray area yeah the only thing that is
certain right now Detroit messed up not
finding this out yeah that's the main
that's almost so unbelievable that you
could not even find it out I mean that
they did it truly is it's kind of that
franchise all right so the speaking of
like investigating draft Simza left go
draft party
still getting a lot of buzz yeah a lot
of people right now are asking for
invitations hmm and I'm starting to
think do we make this an invitation only
is it like Willy Wonka where the golden
ticket shows up on your doorstep just to
get invited yes something I'm thinking
about right now yeah
also there was talk again last night at
Mother's Day about doing this at the
Sims household how excited so I mean
there for all those that are listening
out there we're just not sure we're
definitely gonna have it at my dad's
house yet we're it's like 90% where he
sounds kind of game I don't know if he
really knows what he's getting himself
into so when we do sit down with them at
some point or I have a conversation
about what this will really be yes we'll
see where it goes we're going to have a
draft party we just don't know if it's
gonna be a Phyllis initial draft is
going to be in Nashville which should be
fun nashvegas
but I'll be honest the phil simms house
will be even more fun I got contacted
I'm not gonna say his name if he's
listening he wants to tell me that I can
that's great but a very very very
high-level chef right reached out to me
like an amazing cook yeah and said he
wants to cater the draft party Wow
like I'm talking about major New York
City restaurant he wants to cater it to
which my dad responded he can't Deirdre
said that she would cater Deirdre can
step back
Deirdre find something that's more
expensive she'll step right in and pay
for that
amazing weekend though of fan stuff you
don't see any of it because you don't
have social media we had fans sending us
billboards of Phil Simms in Louisville
Kentucky I somebody sent me a sleeve a
tattoo of Phil Simms someone sent me
really beautiful customized sneakers
that had phil simms painted on the side
yeah and we even got a Chris Sims Oh
someone found a signed Chris Sims
football card on eBay whoa you know what
it was going for $12 $5.00 but he was
able to buy it for 375 that deal that's
what I am a good deal someone sent me
today a Madden of your brother in the
newest Madden is an available free agent
so if you're if you're playing Madden
get on their sign matt sims to your
franchise
get him it like your third quarterback
yeah get him some good reps in the
preseason do do the through the podcast
a favor help Matt Sims out yeah get him
out there other thing Odell Beckham jr.
our birth he is going to be when is he
going to sign a contract right our birth
is that we're calling him just our birth
he's our baby okay I am the father you
are the man I want to know where you're
going with a just said our birth that
went on to the next sign thing you tell
the night a lot of coffee this morning
you are a little jazzed up all over the
place yeah it's okay
and gambling we have we have over a
hundred you're wearing maroon though of
course gotta stay consistent and my
dad's calling you want to pick it up and
that really okay yeah over a hundred and
thirty people have already guessed when
Odell is going to get his new contract
all over United States like every state
New Zealand Italy Germany Australia
Brazil England Denmark Philippines
Ireland Canada listeners from all over
the world are and they're writing some
hilarious stuff someone said they take a
bullet for Chris Simms was great
the earliest guest right now yes is May
23rd right Ryan Gould from the United
Kingdom bet that some are guessing as
late as March April July of next year
what was your official guess again over
that day we said well we didn't find out
the exact training camp day member I
said third day of training camp yeah
that's on you alright so I have to
figure that out look it up well you're
not gonna time third day of training
camp that is Sims as bet I am July 20th
at 4 p.m. head over to the Sims and left
go Twitter it's expect net it's a baby
due date service and then the name of
the game is obj contract go in there log
it you ain't have to login just make a
guess of when Odell will get his new
contract I don't think they've set their
exact date yet I think in the first two
days a holdout third day good first two
days of questioning about Odell Beckham
jr. will drive the Mehra's and Pat
Shermer up to the meeting room to where
they'll go let's figure this out and pay
them whatever the hell we want
I am super excited for him to get a
contract again if you get it right or
the closest one to we will be sending a
of BR swag and maybe by then we'll have
our own we'll have our own swagalicious
of swag being made it's pretty awesome
I'm not gonna lie it's kind of exceeding
my expectations another staple of Sims
and Lefko unfortunately is officially
returning every year an epidemic sweeps
the NFL the ACL epidemic every year guys
start hurting their ACLs and the media
goes this is the most ACLs I've ever
seen there's clearly something wrong
what the hell we've gone back we've done
the research and we realized that every
year about 27 to 31 guys tear their ACL
before the season it's super consistent
unfortunately we got our first one
Fozzy Whittaker yeah Torres ACL
non-contact on-field so the ACL meter is
at one add one poor Fozzy texas guy hook
em horns but it happens this time of the
year I mean I know people forget about
it it's to me when it happens this time
of the year I just say it's like two
things usually a guy is out of shape and
then of course he's in shape and he's
being asked to do something he's not
quite ready for wasn't been cutting for
months it's not quite ready for that
or it can just purely be like wait a
little wait like okay yeah now you're
making these cuts and you're somewhat in
shape but you've bulked up and maybe
lifted at two months without running and
you wait 10 to 15 pounds much and now
you're making these cuts on the body
you're not used to making those would be
the two things I always think of when I
when I hear about these early OTA so ACL
epidemic is at one yeah the other number
that I'm looking at is 497 497 that is
the amount of days since Andrew Luck has
thrown a football and that's crazy when
you put it like that it's absolutely
crazy we did not make a big enough deal
about this a few weeks ago I know when
we were talking about like just how it
was a little bit about he hadn't thrown
yet and yeah right came out was like no
he's still not throwing yet now that
we're on schedule I don't know what
schedule requires a quarterback not to
throw for a year and well it just tells
you that there was obvious complications
with the surgery in the rehab
mean you know again I don't know
everything about this but we've talked
about it where it's his Stamford friend
did the shoulder shoulder surgery
doesn't sound like he got like the
proper guy to do it and then yes I don't
know what happened
with rehab from there but to me this is
I just want to pull up their schedule to
to look at it's curious how can you have
any confidence that he's on schedule
right now like I know I trust Chris
Ballard and I trust Frank Reich but even
if he does come back and he hasn't
thrown for 500 days I mean have you ever
gone in your life 500 days without
throwing a football no never even during
your spleen I mean no definitely not
damn during my spleen I lost your spleen
I applied towards the end of the year I
went to the doctor to talk it out to go
should I play shy come back and play and
you know see if I can lose another kind
of rust is he gonna hang he's gonna have
tremendous rush I think that's where
it's all about left go I think that's
the point is the fact that okay yeah he
can be if he's healthy as healthy can be
and you start training camp it doesn't
matter it's still if he goes in a
hundred percent it's gonna be iffy if he
really is a hundred percent by week one
and I mean with timing rhythm just feel
of throwing the football it's such a
feel position and and and mechanic as
far as throwing the football when you
haven't done that with live people
around you yeah it makes me think that
you know hey they might be able to win
some games early in the year but I don't
think you're gonna see the Andrew Luck
that we think we're gonna say I think
that it's the same reason the Eagles
keep nick foles
because you don't know about Carson
Wentz same reason Colts have jacobi
percent and they didn't trade him for
nobody yeah because you'd even if Andrew
Luck comes back we don't know what we're
getting no you don't know the one thing
that they have at least they can fall
back on what we see what they're doing
right now is what running up that
offensive run game at least it looks
like though maybe you can lean on it to
take Charlie Mac yeah I know it's
nothing special I know but that interior
line with getting quit Nelson that guy
in the second round Braden Smith and
Ryan Kelly being health exactly in a
stands oh it's a pretty good on line
really might only think I realized when
luck got hurt how serious this was going
to I don't think any of us did he felt
like indestructible yes and then Irsay
and those guys really lied to the Colts
fans last year being like we
he's gonna be fine right and we were the
ones going he's barely throwing tennis
balls right now you don't just go from
tennis balls to playing no yeah I don't
I'm scared until I see him throwing foot
I've made the plea and I'll say it again
Andrew Luck or Oliver Luck need to reach
out and they need to go see a doctor
that really saved me and I told you
before Peyton Manning's career the guy
in Denver that's named Greg Ross cop
that would be the guy I would say hands
down he needs to go see because if he's
not throwing and not be able to throw
and create arm speed and all that listen
it's not the ligaments it's nothing like
that the ligaments were healed he did
all they did all the proper surgery it's
the muscles that are shut off from the
shock of the surgery and now nobody's
done anything to kind of flicker them to
get them back on and he's a big strong
athlete and he could probably make some
throws and get it done but he probably
keeps going man it just doesn't feel
right I don't feel like I good yeah it's
because the the really vital muscles for
your shoulder and throwing are probably
not working at the level he's used to
and he's got to find somebody that's the
hardest thing about this and you have a
long-term injury like this all right so
we got to get luck to call you yeah
we'll set up a meeting you'll get him
fixed in Denver yeah and then the
amazing injure luck can return yes
that's what I would help I'm ready for
him to come back I am too I mean this
Andrew Luck was hands-down one of the
five best quarterbacks in football when
he was healthy I mean he was in that
conversation if you want to say seven or
six or four whatever sure but he is in
that conversation he's that special
player what I saw last year and of
course and went yeah that's what I was
seeing out of injury Aaron and you're
exactly right big mobile incredible arm
gamer right slippery yeah and then like
for a guy to do what he did against the
Kansas City Chiefs Chiefs in the
playoffs right that comeback the dive
he's a special special player and the
NFL's better yeah you know what else are
you excited for yeah we got a few for
you today we're gonna start off some
runner ups from honorable mention right
a little thing about Colton Miller
does it make you say whoa the fact that
his dad is Scandinavian and has
Scandinavian bloodlines what the
Patriots have liked a more I like him
more yeah
Miller is kind of scanned it's kind of
Scandinavian yes another runner up Josh
Alan asked about his high energy and his
response was high-five and slapping
butts that's what we do around you whoa
big offseason
oh the bills are giving high-fives and
slapping butts I only look at butts I
don't slap them anymore man or women
though I just look
yeah you've learned I learned a lot of
counseling yes no tapping it in there
anymore no DEP DEP DEP arooo
first real whoa big offseason locker
room placement ooh that's right when you
put a young guy near the serious guys
Philadelphia Eagles Josh sweat sending
him a message putting his locker right
in front of Fletcher Cox Brandon Graham
Derek
Oh Michael Bennett and Tim Jernigan aha
Oh big offseason the rookie is with the
stud keep them in line yes anything no I
mean that's always like this time of the
year it's like and Deon branch's locker
is right next to Tom Brady it's an easy
way to indoctrinate I don't even know if
I'm using they normally put the rookies
all together at this time of the year
they will yeah a lot of the times they
well they might just throw the rookies
and go you're down here so we get down
to 53 and we may you've made the team
and we have a real locker room that will
integrate you with the team budget yeah
rookies you could be like in the
portable lockers that are in the middle
of the locker room this time of the year
yeah that's the way it is as a rookie
but to me what it does for those kind of
guys like Josh sweat who you and I both
have talked about and we know though
excited be a superstar is it just gets
the conference it gets all the ice
broken right away he's right there he's
middle them they're getting naked and
dressed together and yeah warmed up for
the game and tape and ankles together
and he'll be a part of their posse and
he's gonna go okay this is what they're
talking about before practice or it will
help them there's no glass Moses yes who
was your locker next to when you started
oh gosh that's a really good question I
didn't have like anybody notable next to
me I was kind of close to Alstott but
not like right next to him weird in the
rookie clump no I did not get in a
rookie clump I got
I mean men the old one buck place the
whole thing was a clump yeah he always
talked I mean it was pitiful I had an
unidentified fungus on my foot for like
nine months no joke I'm not even like
messing around like to the point where I
went to the doctor and they were like
we're not sure what this is didn't they
have like I'm was a huge medical
outbreak in Tampa Bay well they had the
that was actually at the new facility
there was a little bit worried of the
staph infection but I don't think
anything came of it I think Jojo a
vicious but that was Cleveland it was
Cleveland but the old one buck no love
Co I don't have purple dye on my foot to
stop this fungus that I had it was
unbelievable he's just a constant
reminder that if you think that the NFL
and their billion dollar valuations
genuinely care about the health of their
athletes they're making them walk around
with fungus on their feet yeah somebody
would have lines for showers it's not
leg down anymore down there it's a new
facility yeah there would be like six
working showers for 50 something guys
whoa whoa big offseason holy cow early
workload amounts when a team talks about
really wanting to feature a player and
here we have the Dallas Cowboys they
called Tavon Austin a web back yeah
and want to get him the ball a dozen to
two dozen times per game plus returns on
top of that hmm a dozen to two dozen 24
times a game tavon Austin's touching the
ball this is the new like offense for
the Dallas Cowboys sounds like they're
gonna definitely know or you believe in
this I believe that they're gonna try to
what else do they have that they're
gonna what else do you really look at
douse and go they're gonna hang their
hat on him he's guy yeah Zeke that's
right and then I look at Tavon Austin we
gotta stop looking him as a receiver and
just go know he's Darren Sproles right
that's what he is gonna be going going
forward
third down back slump semis slot
receiver and make him do all those
returns as they dog they're calling him
a web battle [ __ ] I've never heard
that one that you phrase how we've
created edge for pass rushers right
could Webb back be the Darren Sproles
Tavon Austin running back wide receiver
hybrid guy what is why the web but their
explanation
they have a web of things they can do
but I just thought Tavon Austin the guy
that every year people are like man he's
not earning that contract and now the
Cowboys like we're gonna give them all
24 times a game I know
tavon Austin's touching the ball more
than Zeek I gotta be from yeah they're
not gonna that's not gonna happen it
it's an 8 10 12 times a game if Alvin
Kamara can only touch the ball 12 it
sort of easy yeah there's no way to even
Austin's gonna be touching at 24 that
one was compliments of Josh Norris by
the way so thank you for that
information
next whoa big offseason out of the
ordinary coaches we see sometimes guys
get hired military Navy SEALs and we go
this team is adding something well guess
what the Patriots they don't have a
defensive coordinator but they now have
a martial arts expert oh yeah his name
is Master Joachim Cleveland area take
Taekwondo master
he's worked or consulted on 10 NFL teams
his first job Bill Belichick back in
1992 when he was the head coach of the
Browns this guy also taught Danny
Shelton in Cleveland Danny Shelton comes
to New England and it's all about hand
movement right and contact right
Taekwondo master Joakim comes to New
England yes what do you think there's
there is a place for it in the NFL there
definitely oh you see the UFC guys yes
the jujitsu any of that that's usually
what players learn on your lean on even
more because it's more hand fighting the
grappling and things like that but again
I think when you just talk about yeah
the hand fighting body positioning
balance all those things come into play
of martial arts and especially up front
offensive and defensive linemen so it's
that's part of it I know the Brian
Flores thing people are like kind of
amazed about the whole non defensive
coordinator thing that's goes on in New
England he's gonna make you earn your
stripes you don't just get together like
oh here's an extra million dollars now
cuz you have the word defensive
coordinator next to you I'll make you
earn your stripes and your belts and
your black belt black belt master Joakim
I want to go and meet this guy I want to
get taught defensive line hands from a
Taekwondo master
right yes I think that'd be fun it would
be funny I've seen like some of the UFC
or not UFC guys but jiu-jitsu type
fighters push around with like the NFL
players probably do well they get pushed
around at first right and they and
they're not going for real for real
right the amazing thing about those guys
is they have phenomenal muscle stamina
so like if you look over there in the
first minute or two you'll see defense
alignment kind of pushing them all over
the place and they're just kind of
hanging in there but then you look back
over there ten minutes later and that D
lineman is hanging on by his thread
because he's huffing and puffing and the
other guys just a technician and kind of
weird so I understand according to in
your words yka pedia yeah Taekwondo is
about kicking jumping and spinning in a
lot of kicks yeah
Jiu Jitsu always made sense to me
because jiu-jitsu is always about like
using other people's weight against them
right like that always made sense I know
is Danny Shelton gonna be kicking people
listen I was gonna say they're a little
behind the curve on this one that's
that's it you're right I mean they
should be doing everything in that time
was hey Bill it's 2018 you're not in
Cleveland in 1996 any more than we have
this new thing called Brazilian
jiu-jitsu it's Navy or maybe bill so far
ahead that no one's thought of kicking
opponents yet Kings coming into place
yeah mate we're all loosen up Owen
there's no language that says you can't
do a roundhouse kick take a look at this
one incredible here the entire defensive
line the Patriots has kicked the Buffalo
Bills offensive line in the shin they've
all collapsed and now Danny Shelton
sacks Josh out this is incredible I
think it could be a thing I got a new
segment for you it's called are we sure
it's quotes from NFL players that we go
I don't know about that one are we sure
are you sure this one is Warren Sapp on
V to Vega
he was on a podcast and Warren Sapp said
his big concern he goes he likes the
player but quote football players at 350
pounds can't exist in Florida especially
West Coast guys are we sure are we sure
what do you think about this I don't
know what he's trying to say there West
Coast guys like what does he just say
they're not gonna be used to the
humidity was mainly saying three
fifty pounders in Florida is a big issue
hey that's it is an issue I've never
thought of it so are we sure yeah
no we're not sure but I'm 90% sure he
won't be as heavy this year as he was in
years past because you got no choice
training camp in Florida is borderline
torture it just that much different Oh
it falls off you I would literally go
into training camp when I'm Tampa and we
would go into Orlando like in the week
before I would be like just calories
honey just I don't really care and she
would be like sticks of butter on Mike
toast like I just try to bulk up yeah I
was just because I knew like within I
would step on a scale and this would be
most of the most of the team he'd step
on the scale and let's say I'm 232 to
the first day before we start to it is
then the next morning I'd walk on there
and I'm 224 what the hell right sweat
just sweat body being broken so that
isn't this actually great for V to VII
part concern was that he could balloon
to 450 exactly if he's in that heat he
might be a svelte 345 I think so and and
I think with with him and I think them
drafting him so I they're gonna want him
to play more snaps he's probably gonna
have to cut a few pounds down yeah you
know I think it'll probably be better
for him in general I just thought that
was an interesting quote yeah I like
when athletes go it's hot people so it's
like Giancarlo Stanton the weather is
getting better he's gonna hit better
yeah and now your Yankees are like the
scariest thing I've ever seen in my
entire life
are you like loving it I am loving it I
was oh I was curious when when you're a
Yankees fan and you're you're this good
it's still enjoyable yeah you're not
like this is what we do well we haven't
been good and like give like a
legitimate threat to win it in ten years
so you've had some we've got some teams
none of them were a threat none of them
this is why this is why we were all
going no let's get let's get on but
these older guys let's move on because
it was just like oh well limp into the
playoffs and lose the first series no
now we got a chance to dominate the next
82 years alright next are we sure are we
sure Jerry Jones on Romo and Witten from
my standpoint I can't help but say boy I
really dropped the ball not doing enough
not doing enough to get them a Super
Bowl it's
my biggest regret with my time with the
Cowboys was Jerry Jones the real reason
they didn't win are we sure are we sure
Jerry really does think he's important
well of course he does
Jerry's done he's done some good things
he's not the reason they've won or lost
I don't look at Jerry and just go oh
okay it's it's all been a disaster cuz I
am
I I do think the Jones family has a
pretty good eye for talent I respect the
guys they draft and they've taken some
chances on some players I don't like do
you think it's the contracts do you
think it's the Randy Gregory's and the
genomes of the world is signing free
agents a little bit of that and I'll go
back to just like damn sometimes you're
just unlucky I mean the Dez Bryant catch
rule yeah you know that happens ten
years earlier it's a catch but this time
it wasn't you know that the other one
that I always look at it's a 2007 as if
people forget when the Giants went on to
upset the Patriots a year the Cowboys
were the number one seed in the NFC the
Cowboys controlled the divisional
playoff game against the Giants that
year really the majority of the game and
they are going to win the football game
Romo scrambles to his left and I'm gonna
blank on the receiver who drops the pass
Oh Patrick
yes born rot not know not Claiborne he
was a receiver II went to the Chargers
after it'll come to me but either way he
lost he dropped a big pass in the fourth
quarter that would ice the game the game
would have been over it was a third and
seven realm Oh scramble Patrick Crayton
Patrick Crayton yes crane yep Patrick
Crayton he drops a football that's gonna
close the game and end it and then the
Giants get the ball and go down and end
up having the game on he said me I just
it's so funny about Jerry Jones that
he's like guys I'm gonna take this one
we didn't win the Super Bowl the kind of
because of me and it just for me it's
just cherry showing more and more how
much he thinks he genuinely impacts the
team on a day-to-day basis yeah and I do
think he's probably a little hurt that
he didn't get a guys like Witten and
Romo a Super Bowl I mean they're but
what I'm saying is the fact that he
thinks yeah I know I know that's insane
yes well it's in line with most of the
owners in our NFL
yeah you're right all right last are we
sure it's the beautiful
relationship between ben roethlisberger
and mason rudolph it just doesn't stop
apparently Ben texted Mason and said hey
good luck during rookie minicamp and and
Mason and interview said you know I'm
sure when we get in this building in
this room we're gonna be friends are we
sure are we sure that bad and Mason are
gonna be friends at all I'm sure I mean
I don't think they're gonna sure I am I
sure I mean Ben he's BSN or [ __ ] and
anybody he's he's kind of said what he
thought it's not personal against Mason
Rudolph he's not there to babysit him
and make him feel warm and cozy he sent
him a good-luck text message probably
didn't even want to send him that he'll
know it was gonna be reported by
everybody if he didn't yeah so he has to
because then we're all gonna paint him
oh look you didn't even touch the guy
who to go before practice because that
made a difference in Mason Rudolph he
looked at he said oh man I'm gonna
practice good now Ben said good luck he
kind of does sound like though that
Mason gets really pumped about this well
yeah I mean I'm anybody would it's yeah
[ __ ] Ben Roethlisberger right and
he's texting you so it's nothing's
personal there Ben's just told you his
feelings and that's what's it and
they're gonna be fine
by the way Tommy Maddox came out yeah
spoke up for Ben yeah said I don't think
it's a situation where Ben owes it or
that it's his job or whatever his job is
to be the leader of the team and make
sure there's no distractions there are
two separate categories yes and also
said that he thinks that Ben's cockiness
and rudeness are part of the reason he's
so success they are so I'm just glad
that everyone was like tommy maddox
taught you and time acts like now man
I'm not Ben Roethlisberger and Ben
Roethlisberger's not me right let him do
it the way he wants to do some of the
flaws we look at in all athletes or what
makes these guys good in between the
lines though I mean that's just the way
it is whether you want to go like
Lawrence Taylor oh yeah he was psycho
off the field why because he was psycho
on the field that's why it worked I mean
there's a lot of similarities there you
know Odell Beckham jr. you know yeah
he's emotional that's the way he is he's
intense that's why he's a little like
that off the field and on the field is
what makes him awesome it's funny though
I know we want our athletes to be so so
particular a set of skills
yeah all right let's do a little out of
left go field okay left go I wanna click
clear something up member we talked
about Patriots and team captains yeah so
a lot of reddit I love reddit right Bros
sidon the go on reddit broke down the
in terms of captains 27% of their team
high school or college captains the
league average is 40% so they're below
average they win the Super Bowl there
isn't necessarily a direct correlation
between a team filled with captains and
a grid - no not necessarily and I would
think that yeah around a but that would
make sense though that allow 40% of the
team's your X captain's right yes that's
why I get pissed off whenever I hear
like oh these professional players they
don't care as much as the college guys
that's like throw 9 challenge flags and
a middle finger up yours you say that
because those are the guys that led your
college teams and made everybody get in
a huddle and jump around and let's get
excited for the game yes the guys that
are were the stars of the team that
everybody followed that went on to the
NFL it's the guys who cared the most
from your college team that are in the
NFL for the most blood so I hate when
people say that next out of love go
field I love what's a Quan is doing say
Quan says that already Quan he hit the
Quan he's called the gun I'm down a call
in the quad
ok uh he says that he's more than a
running back quote look at what Zeke and
levian are able to do when you look at
those guys they are more than running
backs I view myself as more than a
running back hmm
start it now and if you're an NFL
running back you're not an NFL running
back you're a weapon you are an
offensive piece because in four or five
years when sake one's gonna start and
when the Quan is gonna start negotiating
his next contract I'm an offensive
player yeah I want to have Antonio Brown
money I don't need levy on bail money
right oh man
I'm a weapon you're right um the Kwan as
long as he stays healthy too he's gonna
be able to demand those things I think
that the conversation about this
runningback thing will start to change
over the next few years because we're
gonna see these these just hurt a van
alstyne it's a Webb back we're gonna
consider to see these cases whether it's
Alvin Kamara say qualms Barkley Kareem
Hunt whoever it may be and I think the
tides gonna change to go oh you know
what these guys are athletic enough to
to avoid so many car crashes that change
their careers are shorten their careers
now Ezekiel Elliott will see because
he's a little true in between the
tackles Runner and he and he wins so
many of those car crash battles it's
what makes him great I forgot what my
point was oh there
like what do you think realistically
though like statistics for say Quan this
year like pops into my head I'm a little
bit unsure of how great the giant
softens a big question yeah
thinking again so a thousand rushing
yeah my number was more in the 1350 1400
ran what are you saying like receiving
wise because I think to me when I look
at my things to be better a receiver
well I think he's gonna get a li I'm
gonna say somewhere between fifty and
seventy receptions I think finishes with
seventeen hundred total words yeah and
then I don't know how it's broken I
think that's that's what I would say is
seventeen to eighteen like which is
incredible incredible yes incredible
they're gonna find a way I mean what
Shermer was able to do with Dalvin cook
when he was healthy Landon and in
McKinnon and open up all those receivers
and now he has better receivers and a
say Kwan I think is more talented than
both of those guys yeah his offensive
line isn't as good as was in Minnesota
and I also would take Case Keenum over
Eli Manning right now yeah but no se
Quan is yeah I I see seventeen to
eighteen hundred total yard I'm with you
I think it's someone in that range too
it's funny like I see all these articles
over the weekend city Quan is the
favorite to be Offensive Rookie of the
Year yeah no crap however now that I say
it out loud the fact that five
quarterbacks went in the first round and
he's the the runaway for rookies I know
but he was one Baker Mayfield was too
and Josh Allen was three I would have
put Sam Donald yeah but you don't know
they're he's gonna play you don't know
if he's gonna play the weapons around
him I think are in question I was
surprised to see Josh Allen that high
then I was like well I guess it's
buffaloes teams good and they thought
and he's expected to play because people
are like ancient McCarran I saw this
today that Joe Flacco did not reach out
to Lamar Jackson I love in this I'm
loving these guys that have never been
challenged in their lives in terms of
their NFL once they became the guys the
bends the flack goes the Eli's the
Philip Rivers whatever and were stunned
that they don't want to help out the
young guy I get it yeah but when I
brought up that oh no they're gonna use
them like in the laboratory and Lamar
Jackson could be a wide receiver some
people were like oh I don't like that
there is something I've had some of that
push back too
what do you think well because we were
leading the charge Lamar's not a wide
receiver yeah we don't think that he's
going to be a wide receiver we've kind
of come around to the just get him on
the field they're getting scared there
what everybody the but I've realized cuz
I actually was on a Baltimore radio
station today and I think they're their
thing there he is if he does good a
receiver they might just keep him there
and he might not want that no they did
not draft him in the first round for
anything but quarterback yes that's what
he's done his whole life it's the only
sport in position he's played his whole
life is quarterback football so again I
am for one to get him out there just to
get used to the speed of the game and
those things I think a lot of the points
that we have made and that Mike came
from my dad and Bill Cowher originally I
think are spot on I think it will do a
lot of good I'm not saying you put him
out there for 40 snaps a game I'm saying
there's a package of 10 to 15 plays that
are Lamar Jackson plays in the game plan
every week and you call a handful of
them in certain situations and he gets
to run out there and line up a receiver
you know maybe take a speed sweep but
trust me Baltimore Ravens drafted this
guy and gave up assets they didn't do it
to Tran to give a to try to transform
some kid who was a quarterback into a
wide receiver so let me ask you
I remember Kordell Stewart and I
remember being like I think this guy
should play and it never really happened
now Kordell Stewart was the sixtieth
pick in the draft towards the end of the
second round yeah the expectations for
Lamar are so much higher than Kordell
yeah I don't really remember Cordell
coming out right but my fear I guess
over talked about this wide receiver
slash position is it always seemed like
it it was a detriment to kordell's
development as a whole do you remember
that the same way I mean I really do I
was I was very much a part of it no I
think that they maximize what they could
get out of Kordell out of the
quarterback position I think that he had
some flaws about playing quarterback
that you know he just had in general and
and they did the best to get him on the
field get him up to speed and when they
felt like he was up to speed and then
the Pittsburgh lost that Super Bowl or
the the Dallas Cowboys right and they
lose 27:17 in Super Bowl 30 Neal
O'Donnell throws the two interceptions
that gave him the excuse to go okay now
we got our we got our guy anyways we
kind of
to make him the guy yes and this gives
us the jumping point and they'd went
from there and of course they had
success that's what yes we're yeah they
went to the AFC Championship game with
Kordell Stewart the next year and lost
to the Denver Broncos and John Elway in
a really close football game right way
made a huge throw on third and seven to
win it so that is no I think the flaws
we saw from Kordell Stewart at
quarterback were just the flaws he had I
don't think you had anything to do with
it being receivers launches you're not
concerned about that no I'm not I think
this kid is a natural QB I really do
like I told you the thing I was most
shocked by and I wrote in my notes and
you read some through something is how
pure he plays the position I think it
gets lost in translation because we see
highlights and you know they show the
five best plays of the day and for them
were runs and one was throw and they
just go he's a runner he's a runner and
I want to go no he dropped back 45 other
times and stayed in the pocket perfectly
what's more likely to happen first Lamar
Jackson comes out and says they're
playing me at wide receiver too much or
Joe Flacco comes out and says you're
ruining my flow in the game by putting
Lamar Jackson in there occasionally a
quarterback which quote do you think
could happen first
I think that Joe Flacco one what happens
if I just I see that happening like week
four yeah just like a big third down
Lamar goes out there for a read option
where they don't convert and he just
enjoy slow yeah yeah I do I do think
that again I want to say this for Joe
Flacco to just like I said they don't
have to send a good luck text before
they go out for practice there's there's
no rule that says you have to do that
like the that's what it's becoming a
thing right now it is it's to become
this big thing all ever since Brady
Garoppolo oh we think we don't know if
they really liked him and Brady maybe
caught him out of town I didn't want to
teach him what profession does that
happen in I don't I don't know I mean to
do big-time doctors here like the New
York special surgery hospital did they
text the other big-time doctors their
first day of working go good luck with
the scalpel today I had a conversation
with Joe for a about us and he was
talking about how you know I wish I had
more mentors and stuff and I said here's
the thing
if somebody comes into bleacher report
and they want to be an NFL podcast host
I'm probably not going to help that like
I'm gonna be a nice person
but I'm not gonna like tell them what
you do this is how I come up with my
ideas for the show every night you want
to come over and take them for me and I
would also say though in the NFL where
the average career span is two and a
half I am not helping anybody it's too
hard forget about this isn't normal life
for like I could be a media person for
like 40 years like NFL guys have like
two years it could be over like that
like Dez Bryant doesn't have a job right
now and he was a top twenty guy like
yesterday right so I'm looking at and
going if anything these guys that are
helping the Sam Bradford's the Alex
missed the world all that they're there
past that point of their career where
they can lead the guy Flacco still
thinks he can be the cop yes he does
Phillip still thinks he can be the guy
yeah Ben Eli they don't think they're
dead yet Alex Smith has been dead his
entire career like in terms of public
perception right but no I don't think
they need to help anybody no it's it's a
selfish sport that's the way it is you
have to take care of you I mean build
bail you you can't have your head coach
day and do your job and then you were
trying to tell other people to do their
job - oh let me help you out with your
job no in the NFL that's where it does
become a selfish spot as a player in US
athlete at times because you just got to
worry about you because you are the
business and you have to take care of
you all the time out of love go field
yeah I have better today you've
literally already said that today today
yeah
not on the show no on the show you know
yeah go back to like the 10 minute mark
you were like by the way maroon yeah so
the safety market right now is in
shambles in terms of free agent where
did Vacarro go today I didn't see that
no he's visiting somebody every
offensive or defensive position saw at
least one player get a contract worth 30
million dollars or more except safety
Kurt Coleman got 16 and a half from the
Saints before free agents it's the
biggest contract they've gotten for
different positions had at least five
players earned 20 million or more on
average the seven highest-paid
quarterbacks
earn up to thirty eight point nine
million the Safety's averaged eight
point six two so cornerbacks are making
nearly five times as much as safety
kicker's 34 million are worth nearly as
much as strong safeties thirty four
point four million kickers and strong
safeties are comparable in terms of
their contracts here's my out of left
Kofi I'd like to hear it we have a white
space in the NFL passing is skyrocketing
we're seeing teams utilizing big
safeties as linebackers currently on the
market Kenny Vaccaro Eric Reid trae
Boston Mike Mitchell TJ Ward
I mean TJ Ward is a fries and all these
guys yeah I am scooping up all of these
safeties if it's gonna if I can get two
or three safeties for the cost of one
corner then if I'm a really good team
I'm bringing two or three of these
safeties into camp and I'm paying them
six million dollars a year and I'm going
the nf2 the season I might drop a corner
like that fourth or fifth corner that
could play special teams
I am stocking up on these really good
safeties at a really low price there is
an availability right now to maximize
this what do you think I'm actually you
know we do this stuff live and I didn't
know you were gonna bring up this topic
so I'm actually kind of like flushing it
out in my brain right now gone oh that's
interesting I haven't thought about that
I didn't really read it I knew there was
safeties that with big names on the
street it's such an important position I
guess what I don't understand and this
is my brain went to this place first and
you know you of course challenge me or
tell me I'm stupid if you think I'm
stupid but I think the first thing is
it's become a very popular position and
of course it's become popular and the
fact that it's very needed in our league
and I think this athlete exists a lot in
college football right now to where we
don't need the recycled seven-year guy
we got a whole bunch of them coming to
the league every year Jesse Bates Justin
Reed minkum Fitzpatrick Derwin James all
these other guys that we go who they
were a corner but they could play safety
in the NFL linebacker can make them a
strong safety or whatever they're a
linebacker a little bit light but they
be a great safety exact remain admin
exactly or torella Terrell exactly right
that's right yes so exactly there's too
much supply I think
there might be a lot of supply let me
ask you if you're a big-time contender
yes would you want you know like Jesse
Bates went to the Texans right so the
Texans get their young guy for the
future yeah but what about adding like a
vet for like four and a half five
million that you know is good I just
think that veterans do really what like
I think Raiders are gonna have a really
good start to the year because they're
gonna be so veteran right might tail off
right but just why not have a bunch of
more safeties on your team personal
it'll happen like these guys I don't
think this this these are the type of
excuse me isn't burping gross these are
the type of guys that I think will get
signed a few weeks in the training camp
a weekend somebody gets dinged up there
kind of just they're not worried about
the position overall and simple OTAs
where we're just putting in base
defenses and we're not worrying about
getting exotic nickel-and-dime packages
out there where we're mixing where Kenny
Vaccaro is the middle linebacker like
it's very basic at this point right the
market and just to probably do evaluate
some of these guys that they go we got
this position already we're gonna give
our guy a shot and see if he can do
something right now I mean this is
interesting that's what happen with TJ
Ward in Denver there's that all those
young guys Justin Simmons is of the
world and stuff yeah I know yeah there's
a part of me or so like seven or eight
years ago I would a gun if you want to
be a good defense in the NFL you better
have good safeties I would have gone
Safety's first I don't have safeties
like Seattle Seahawks or Oh Thomas Cam
chance or Edie Reed and the Baltimore
Ravens what do you think I just think
the league has changed a little bit and
with the rules and just being so
offensive heavy I just think man-to-man
corners are more in demand and more
important to the football team now
almost as much as quarterbacks and left
tackles and pass rushers it's right in
that conversation yeah it's interesting
I think you and you can find the
safeties I always bring up Malcolm
Jenkins yeah the guy that can stop the
run but then also cover the slot
receiver right big right the other thing
I was thinking about is like the mic
kiseki z' of the world yeah like the
non-blocking tight ends everyone
suddenly cooler right it's like the the
weird tight end receiver that wasn't
fast enough to take in the top off but
also wasn't strong enough to like set
the edge in the running right right
we're like blocked it's
we're cool with it now I know I know it
some teams are cool with the spread type
of football game and we're gonna use
this bigger type body who might not be
necessarily the twitchy is quickest type
of guy but yeah he's a big body that we
could throw one on one balls to give him
the ball in the flat and he might break
a tackle and run for something random
thing I just thought of the Quan yeah
we are you gonna be upset the the Giants
also signed Jonathan Stewart if he
vultures like 10 touchdowns away from
say Quan say Kron busts out like a
30-yard run down to the two they put in
Jonathan Stewart gets the touchdown I
don't care cuz I don't give a damn about
fantasy or anything like that that's
gonna piss me about stats yeah I don't
care because if we're gonna call
ourselves to the players podcast I think
we need to we need those things for the
our guys like say Quan ya take 15 big
shots off of them again lettin go ahead
let Jonathan story cuz I want to see
sake well get to the next big contract
that he's gonna get screwed over in this
first one yeah but they're also in the
Contra thing you know you'd only had
four touchdowns your rookie here yeah I
got us down there every time oh yeah
that's the worst though as a player I
had some years like in college football
where I was I wanted to be like damn my
receivers got tackled like the one like
12 I think it's a central Cedric Benson
got demoted and I want to be a damn my
30 touchdown passes could have easily
been 40 something but you know we
tackled it the five tackle to the four
or whatever hey you ever had like a like
an upset like like in the huddle with a
player that really wanted it and wasn't
getting it or got taken out after a big
play like the NFL or something like that
that's a good question I mean I got
yelled at one of my first preseason
games cuz I gave a receiver I think I've
told you a signal on spider 3 why banana
spot or two I yeah this is a spider
three I'm like what's the difference I
left it so it goes 3 is odd odd to the
left and the protection knows it has to
go that way I so you're telling me that
spider - I been out of the - just means
to the right yeah and spider 3 means to
the left all the three why isn't it
spider one banana that's not number so
that's a very good question I don't know
you're right I don't
absolutely provide your office - number
so spider 3y banana yes to the left
right so you're gonna play action to
laugh I action to the tailback flow
action at tight ends gonna run the
little flag route at the back of the
endzone right yeah
and I gave the guy on the back side he's
gonna run like a little shallow cross it
wasn't one-on-one so I gave him a little
hang loose I was like I run a little
faint I'll throw it up there for you
it's catch throw a great ball I'm like
up man I'm the man's more in SAP runs
out a great job everybody said they call
him the touched hey yeah they caught the
touchdown I mean I dropped it in there
perfect beautiful throw people and I run
out and I'm getting close to the
sidelines and I started to get closer
I'm going damn is he looks like he's
angry and it's Gruden and I'm like what
the [ __ ] and I'm like he's not angry I
mean I start to get close and he grabs
me by the arm he goes what the [ __ ] are
you doing out there [ __ ] change in my
plays because we don't we don't signal
on spider 3 why banana
oh that was like holy ground you don't
do that on that play
but did you ever have like an upset
Michael Pittman when all stop stolen
time I'm trying to think just off the
top of my head done I'll think of a few
let me think over those I'll tell you
Chris Johnson a few times his rookie
year see j2k Titans LenDale White used
to still get the inside of five yards he
not that he like would throw a fit but
he'd have like a drive of like four or
four carries 82 yards no touchdown
touchdown to lend ly triangle one and
that I know did like in knowing him at
times to go like damn I did all the work
what was an upset CJ 2k yeah I ever tell
you the the interview when I embarrassed
myself to Chris Johnson so I was gonna
do a Skype interview with CJ 2k yes
Johnson and they gave me a list remember
Paul our book sir he would always be
like you should try rapid-fire and I was
like Paul I hate rapid-fire like it's
not a real interview you're just asking
random questions and I was typical ego
left goes like I'm just gonna wing it
me and Chris Johnson are gonna vibe
we'll connect and he gets on there the
first thing I do is go Chris man I can't
believe that you play with a grill like
where'd you get the grill a Baba he goes
getting a grill is my teeth and I was
like what do you mean he goes no I have
gold teeth and I was like all right man
and I like picked up the the rapid-fire
question so I was like so peanut butter
or jelly because I just have no idea
where to go but I'm he had he had the
hair he had the the the actual gold
teeth what was upset chris johnson like
like just shake his head morning and say
anything yeah nothing but you know
something's wrong
and then you know somebody on the team
like hey you all right man any bit you
know he just like he would brush it
under there like just and then
glendale's coming over super pumped oh
yeah like a seventh touchdown dance when
a running back steals from another
running back is that like a delicate
thing like can he not go back to the
sideline and be too excited no he can
he's fine it we all that you all have
your roles in the end of yeah but i do
think that they probably realized they
were screwing him over at some point and
finally like okay we got to give him
some of these touchdowns some of these
touches towards the end of the year yeah
and then as we got and you know i left
after that year but at two years two and
three then he started to get more of the
the carries inside the 20-yard line
vince young could have worked out with
him in the backfield that would have
been diagnosed yet yeah I remember when
they took Chris Johnson he was a wide
receiver out of East Carolina and it was
like why would you take this guy and
then I watched the highlights from
college and I went he stiff-armed seven
guys at that weight it's unreal I never
said I mean I'm superhuman strength to
be that size he was like 195 running
between the tackles I was always a that
was the most amazing thing to me I mean
of course his speed was but the way he
could take on blockers and I still stand
by this I still I think I'd witness I
would have a Super Bowl ring if he
didn't have a high ankle sprain and her
divisional playoff game in 2008 when we
lost the Ravens his rookie year with her
year there he started off the year
thirteen to no wasn't no tena no like I
forgot the Titans were that good yeah
and he got hurt against who their
bravin's in the divisional game which we
were we were dominating we were pushing
the Ravens around everywhere Kerry
Collins is Kerry Collins we fumbled the
ball three times inside the 20-yard line
we really dominated the football game
had those turnovers and it changed the
game it's also the game the delay of
game happened and they let Joe Flacco's
in a rookie season snap the ball he
converted like a third and 20
act up I'm like his own one-yard line
all right so we had a lot of breaks go
against us that game did the Ravens win
the Super Bowl they lost the Pittsburgh
and then Pittsburgh beat the Cardinals
right right yes that was my closest shot
ever huh Roy Williams Texas now he might
have said some [ __ ] every now and then
sorry I've sworn at least a few times
today but he might have been in the
huddle a few times and been like seems
Sam's [ __ ] that place seems just
throwing up to me like he would he was
the kind of what would Mac Brown do if
you changed his play yeah I could I
could get away with it a little bit with
really with Roy Roy was like Cedric they
were like God's gift to Texas right they
could if I went over there was like hey
Roy told me to change it they I go oh
okay Roy told him to change it okay
everybody Roy told me change it it's not
as good as this
I love you've heard this this is your
sports player that raps that your must
be happy with right now
no no so there's a bunch of music that's
coming out of the NFL right now yeah I
mentioned Arian Foster a lot I was
thinking and that album I really really
liked apparently recently retired Tom
Bali put out a dancehall record which is
interesting know this guy you don't know
this is there's a pyre though let me see
I I have it's cold Beasley oh my gosh
are you kidding me I definitely wasn't
over there you would have never guessed
hear this this another song this is
shock value
this is cold Beasley cold Beasley Wow
his album art looks like a combination
of Jack Handey and Drake
now I didn't expect this I'm shocked
alright so deserves a white boy supreme
title I'll tell you that much he's got a
song called Rookie of the Year where he
goes I always got my man's back got a
support deck I cut the route shorts to
the home II don't get sack he actually
didn't do that that was a love Co
original he's got another song though
called coach him up
the dude Jason Garrett haters calling
The Clapper man's been a coach of the
year with the respect of a long snapper
that's yours that line I know but the
best thing is I could do this all day I
could just make Dallas Cowboy raps I'm
gonna make this one off the top
I got owner with mad things he buy me a
new home I got nothing no but yeah like
here look at the album art it's him
looking into a mirror wearing a helmet
but in the mirror he doesn't have a hell
no my god doesn't it kind of like Jack
Handey like they love you you're you're
great and people like you yeah Colby's
little Beasley here here's a song called
stereotypes I'm impressive is Lehrer
really it upsets me I don't like it at
all really I don't like the whiny small
rap voice he sounds very popular it is
draped [ __ ] in his style
why I just think it's pretty good b2 yes
so he's look the one thing that I love
about what we do here is we care about
the people in the NFL yeah this is
clearly something that cold Beasley
loves today he's got a talent at it he
apparently gets done a gamer's like oh
man I got a job I got to drop that pass
Kobe's that gotta lay down the track you
know what because I talked it out let me
just play this one song Arian Foster's
rap name is Bobby Fino
and he has a song that I think should be
like a song of the summer
it's called watermelon sunrise I'm just
gonna play a little bit right now
he has like actual instrumentation I
think this song is really good I just
sounded like J Cole right there
it has a very J Cole sound and he talks
about like very Jake whole thing Z of
being yourself and all that he just
listens this part here this is good so
when I hear Cole Beasley I'm like I
don't think Cole's bad it's just a
different style yeah Cole Cole don't be
such a hater on the white rapper let's
go well I think I know we haven't made
it hard on a lot of people yeah and for
me the whole like it just sounded very
eight-mile ish yeah why do you go to
compare white rappers to white rappers
why are you sweating just freestyling I
got nervous with the respectable long
snapper I'll be on CNN more than Jake
Tapper okay looking dapper whoo go on so
this is the time of the year man where
all the main NFL websites where I get my
news it's all whoa big officers and the
really good content is on reddit the
people of reddit are amazing I love
reddit and there are some questions on
there that I think are super fun and I
want to do reddit questions
all right props to the people of reddit
what
so one two three five six pick a number
one two three five second umber we're
gonna go with number two - this is from
reddit the only one that I forgot to
write down the name of the person that
posted this one apologizing picking
another number which coach historically
was the most hated by his own players
does anything come to mind
great reddit question the one that was
mentioned with the question was Bobby
Petrino it included a quote from Mike
Zimmer where he said he's a gutless
bastard quote that I don't give a [ __ ]
yeah Joe it was a quote and then the
reporter said I don't know if we can use
faster and he said how about this
gutless mf'er you can use that so Bobby
Petrino easily it would be one of those
guys he hated Bill Parcells I do think
at the time when he's coaching you when
you're coaching Emily maybe Belichick a
little bit too definitely but when
you're done you look back at it and go
man there was a lot of really valuable
lessons there I saw a quote about rich
coat ight yeah that during one of the
games he went for two and afterwards
they said why did you go for two there
and he said honestly it was raining and
the ink on my sheet started running and
I didn't know what to do
that's for its code type which is
amazing but what other players do you
think we're real coaches were really
hated by their team like I got him I
mean I feel like buddy Ryan had a few
offensive guys who hated him back in the
day right because he was so always
friendly to the defense I'm just trying
to think of like some big-name guys you
know know you know Jimmy Johnson had the
feud with Troy Aikman a little early on
in their career but man really hated
their coaches dammit I wish I could have
a better answer for you I don't know if
I got anything for you right off the top
of my head alright I wasn't sure though
if it was gonna be the yelling coaches
or I was gonna be like a lazy coach that
the players hated you know what I mean
like I wasn't sure where it would really
go yeah it could be anything it can be
you know it's not always the yelling
coaches - it can be the coaches that are
nice but they're just they're you know
they're BS sirs - that's what I was
throwing yes like I don't know if like I
I'm not gonna say a Jeff Fisher but I
know he had some people at the end but
you're the BS
are the ones I'm sure there's a lot of
guys that don't like Ben McAdoo
definitely not yeah obviously I'm not
even thinking about some of those guys
like the the short short shelf career
guys like of course think of substantial
players like you know again people think
Bill Walsh was always loved by everybody
in the 49ers that's not the case either
I mean we know that Joe Montana had
issues with them yeah and there were
other guys as well cuz he rode players
hard but I don't know I'll think about
that maybe if I come up with something
good I'll light it
let's do one more one three five or six
let's go with one one would you rather
have miles Garrett or Joey Bosa on your
team for the next five years
this one posted on reddit by Ben King 18
am Ben claims it's a great miles Garrett
Joey Bosa five years Josh can't miss if
you could have gun to my head no I'm
going with miles Garrett over Joey Bosa
I am yeah Joey Bosa has had some great
statistical years put up the numbers
miles Garrett a little underwhelming in
terms of the statistical output yeah
you're going Garrett yeah I am I'm going
to Garrett's special I mean so is Joey
Bosa but Garrett's like once every five
six type of years type of guy to come
off the edge I mean yes you know what's
the difference between them for someone
like me that doesn't watch all the film
of these yeah no I think he's a hair
more explosive a hair more of a bigger
natural bigger man I should say just
altogether yeah mouths Garrett is a free
one of the freakiest guys to ever play
in the sport and yeah Joey Bosa I
think's had somewhere like 23 sacks over
his first two years well man Myles
Garrett member let summer I get he had
the foot injury he only played half the
year and I think if I'm gonna look it up
as we're talking here but I'm pretty
sure he ended up with like seven and a
half sacks where it just was real sneaky
under the radar and I'm gonna get
through a seven sex seven sacks so he
played in 11 games yeah started nine
eleven games seven sacks yeah not bad
it's not bad it's but he had a better
year than people notified it as or gave
it cry forgot that's a thing too with a
lot of these rookies is you have to
monitor the injuries in the beginning of
the year in the offseason because we
were talking about like the ACL tears
yeah a lot of these rookies get banged
up
for the year starts cuz they're not used
to it not used to it and the coaches are
stupid I mean the coaches are all like
oh we drafted them we got to see if we
worth where we drafted them tomorrow
we're gonna throw them out there and
we're gonna make him do conditioning and
run full-speed practice tomorrow even
though he hasn't run in six weeks
I mean how many times we have to see
that did we have to throw Dante Fowler
out there day one to see if he could
rush off the edge tell me how that
worked out for Jacksonville you're right
you know what was Oh stay one he's got
to go full-speed off the edge even
though he hasn't done anything with a
football team in like six weeks I'm
gonna ask you another one yeah this is
from straight cash homey without the me
uh would you rather have as your team's
quarterback going forward Jimmy
Garoppolo or deshaun Watson hmm I'm
still gonna go with the Shawn mmm I mean
I like Jimmy J they've played basically
the same amount of games really I feel
like we've seen Jimmy G in a bunch of
different situations yeah yeah I saw
Watson special I mean I never found
myself ever that was the first time last
year in the Seattle game when he's got
spun around and threw that touchdown
pass remember that left go like he got
spun around on the five-yard line and
then threw the touchdown pass that was
the first time I was like damn I'm
watching Aaron Rodgers like I was the
first time I've ever that's ever come
out of my mouth where I've said holy cow
I'm watching somebody that I think is
gonna be the best player in football he
exposed the Chiefs defense on Monday
Night Football ya know the bangles well
no that was the first one I was the
first one Thursday sheeps was the next
Sunday the bengals he ran for a 50-yard
touchdown that won the game room and it
was he couldn't figure anything out and
he throw to DeAndre Hopkins like
everyone's that game then he explode he
exposed the Chiefs then he dropped like
40 on the Seahawks and he put up it was
the Patriots
I think the chili on the Patriots right
yeah I know you I think you're the mole
are you more excited about deshaun
Watson or Pat mahomes it's it's very I
could say going to this year my home's
just because we haven't seen him al but
it's very close I mean those are two
guys that I mean yeah right now I'm
giving it to my homes because I've seen
DeSean DeShawn's coming off the ACL
injury
I think he's gonna be totally fine but
yeah my Holmes was my my guy coming out
of the draft who would you have for the
next five years my homes are Watson
probably Watson yeah for right now I
gotta say rather have lots and her
whence hikes
he's deshaun Watson your favorite young
quarterback he's that were realizing I
think I think he is yeah - Sean Watson
is Chris Sims number one young
quarterback yeah under the age of 26 I
love just wow yeah I do
I really like to Sean and I like his
demeanor because he's not like you know
he's not yeah he just he plays it
low-key and I used to Mario does
demeanor except when he gets on the
field it's it's the little glimpses of
Mariota where he stands over the guy but
all the time yeah but off the field he's
super chill super chill John Watson yeah
I don't realize I'm a big fan yep
alright uh mascot battle yeah before we
get to the results from last week we had
two random ones here the New England Zoo
has named a Nigerian Dwarf goat after
nick foles
heard a San Francisco Zoo has named a
Snow Leopard Jimmy G who wins in a fight
a Snow Leopard or a Nigerian Dwarf goat
I gotta take this yeah well you think
that you're a Siberian white tiger so it
goes together now the mascot battle phil
simms the Honorable Phil Simms not
available to judge because he had to do
a commercial the votes came down 184 to
a hundred and sixty-three 53% to 47% in
the battle of a giant versus a jet for
my argument was so bad the jet beat you
by six percent the jet officially be the
giant which means two two two two I've
beaten you with the giant and bear lion
right and you've beaten me wicked over
Bob hatred Buccaneer and Erlich score
and dolphin Paul Brown I got hosed on
that so that means
one through six you have to pick one
right now and that will be our battle
for Wednesday all right let's go for
four digit number four and it is a
three-way battle which means vendrick
will be arguing for one we're allowed to
do three ways we're gonna do a three-way
battle vendrick's gonna have to be a
part of it if he's not then I don't know
but do you want the first second or
third animal why don't you just tell me
and I'll pick them no you has to be
random all right I'll take the second
one what's what am I getting and which
one is venture getting well you should
get the first one so I get first you get
second okay that means I am representing
a falcon you are representing an eagle
and Fenric is representing a Seahawk so
glad I took the second trouble I have to
really figure out a way and I need to
like read National Geographic and see
how Falcons can outmaneuver Eagles it's
gonna be hard I love the vendrick as a
CEO he is a CEO
yeah I think alright he's not here right
I say we gang up on him yeah and we
eliminate him
yeah just eliminate him right away right
then we focus on the right we just
you're gonna try and stab me in the back
I know how you were oh definit now just
notice I just I actually want to stab
you in the face just with big eagle
claws right in your face speaking of
former Falcons DeAngelo Hall's retiring
yah man okay what kind of career was I
remember I was talking to somebody from
Virginia hmm when he came out of
Virginia Tech yeah I had never heard a
corner get talked about as much as
similar to Deion Sanders as DeAngelo
Hall Yeah right like a four three four
three something yeah ran and he was
cocky baller verge a black yes day one
day why I could still remember 2004 his
rookie season we're playing in Atlanta
and he is our defensive players are
talking trash to him and he's letting
them know I remember it he's letting
them know you know screw you I'm top
five pick and he also let them know how
much money he had in the bank already
and that shut that conversation up quick
was he he was confusing for the rookie
salary cap so he got like you know 25
million dollars and before he played a
game
right but he was a phenomenal football
player all-around player - you know
tackles zone man whatever it may be I
don't know I don't think he's gonna be
in the Hall of Fame I think he's an NFL
legend I threw him some damn pics I know
that he's real off me yup he did what
made him so good was it just sheer speed
yeah and he had a really great feel for
the game I mean he was a smart football
player he to me reminded me a little bit
of Marcus Peters in terms of he would
try and and go quarterbacks index very
very much I think that was in very
that's a very good comparison he's very
similar to Marcus Peters probably that's
quite the size but yeah and Peters
wasn't as fast as him no no definitely
not but and then you know again just to
show what he's in the last few years he
went to safety it shows he's a football
player he was never just like a cover
corner that didn't want to do anything I
will say though the hard knocks when
they follow the Texans remember when the
Texans and the Washington Redskins
scrimmage yeah there's an amazing scene
of Hopkins battling DeAngelo Hall right
and like Hall puts his hand on him and
Hopkins I think is like a rookie or a
second-year player and he's like don't
touch me and they went out there the
next play and Hopkins broke DeAngelo
Hall's ankles so bad that Hall hat got
injured like the clip is incredible he
stopped Gautam twice and halls knees
bucket out yeah I I think there's a few
things just to kind of wrap up the show
one people are upset that we're very
hard on Matt Ryan um so we're gonna walk
it back a little bit I don't want to be
that hard on Matt Ryan and just it's a
lot of money for a guy that you don't
have if you haven't liked number nine I
think it is and a lot of people have
said in the past that we're a little bit
too hard on the Andre Hopkins and I
think that's true too because what
Hopkins has done with the quarterbacks
there is really it is definitely
incredible I mean DeAndre Hopkins is a
really good player again it's just yeah
I don't put them in the class as some of
those other guys but no that's all good
he's still demand am i if I could play
quarterback I'd still pick the under
happens to be my receiver dude I didn't
mean it like that
so as always guys hit us up on social at
Sims and luf go Twitter Instagram make
sure you get on there and vote for the
Odell Beckham jr. contract the winner
whoever gets closest we've got about a
hundred and thirty guesses right now
let's keep it going your
get some swag you're probably the first
one to get the Simpson left go swag and
then just keeping us on iTunes come and
Super Bowl champ Eagles gonna dominate
on Wednesday
Falcons baby what is an Eagle One guys
love you so much for Sims peace out
homies Hendrick would say good evening
from the lef koe man holla holla holla
holla holla holla holla we'll talk to
you guys on Wednesday so special guests
in store we'll see you then